hello everyone this is samir from audio
science review
today we're going back to school again
but don't worry
it won't be a super dense topic but it's
a useful one and a question that comes
up all the time which is
why don't you test with square wave and
people tend to think that that square
wave is a magical signal
in that it brings out measurements that
you wouldn't see with a typical
sine wave so
i thought i'd talk about why i don't do
it by
doing some demonstrations for you so
that you get a good practical feeling
for
what the issue is with uh square wave
testing is
i've got my audio precision analyzer
again running this the user interface
for it
um i've set it to 10 kilohertz and the
signal up here if you can read it says
square so it's
been told to generate the square wave
look to the right does this look like a
square wave to you
it doesn't right it looks like a pretty
sine wave how's that possible how could
it be a sine wave
when i'm asking it to generate the
square wave
well if you uh could keep up with my
last
long and complicated video on on fourier
transform you would know why
because i explained to you that square
wave when you decompose it
it becomes an infinite range of
sine waves that you have to add together
to make a square wave otherwise you
don't have a square wave
so if you look on the left you see why
this is not the case
here that our bandwidth for capturing
that signal
is only 22 kilohertz so the generator in
the analyzer is generating a square wave
and i'll show you in a second
but because on the receiving side we're
truncating everything after 22 kilohertz
we cannot capture the third harmonic of
10 killers so the tone i carefully set
it to be 10 kilohertz
so the first hormone uh odd harmonic
that you need to make as
a square wave would be 30 kilohertz but
since we truncate everything at 22
kilohertz
we basically just have the primary tone
which uh
is a sine wave so the fourier transform
works
so notice what happens now if i set this
to bandwidth to 500 kilohertz
all of a sudden we get a full square
wave
why because we're capturing many many
many odd harmonics
of 10 kilohertz and that starts to look
almost like a square wave now if you
don't believe me
let's uh look at the uh
what a fourier transform of a square
wave is and this is a wikipedia page on
uh
square wave that you can prove that your
leisure
it is written by math people so you're
going to get totally lost
but one key thing for it is that if you
look in here this is what it
winds up being in the expansion of this
series
and it says basically you take a bunch
of sine waves and this basically
translates into odd sine waves
um and you add them up together and you
get a square wave
but look at what you have to add from k
equals one to what
infinity so this is why i say you need
to have infinite amount of energy
to make a square wave if you don't have
infinite amount of energy then you don't
have a square wave
now in our audio systems
we care about what we can hear what can
you hear can you hear above 20 kilohertz
you cannot even if you're young maybe
you hear a little bit more than that
but that's it so very quickly we
truncate the bandwidth of any signal
that we throw at the system
so the notion of a square wave it just
doesn't apply certainly not to digital
audio if you have cd
by definition you only have 22 kilohertz
of bandwidth so if you truncate that you
only get
somewhat of a square wave at lower
frequencies and i can
show you that but at higher frequencies
you basically
do not so if i go back to my uh
22.4 kilohertz and i make this uh
let's say 100 hertz
now we start to get a square of ray but
notice that it's not a great square wave
because we don't have all the
frequencies this slanting that you see
in here
happens because we're basically limiting
the bandwidth as i mentioned at 22
kilohertz so
your cd format which is the most common
digital format that we stream
can't do square wave nothing in life can
really do square wave
because this transition from zero to max
needs to be
needs to have a zero slope and when you
don't have zero slope
you get artifacts in there so
people get a generator an analog
generator sometimes you get an rf
generator and i have signal generators
that go to hundreds of megahertz
and you can get a beautiful square wave
out of those because it goes to hundreds
of megas
and then you stick that into an
amplifier and then they look at the
output they say whoa
you know it did this or did that but
that's not a proper test because your
amplifier is not designed to play back
hundreds of megahertz your speakers
certainly don't play hundreds of mega
or hundreds of kilohertz even and so it
becomes a test of really a bandwidth
test there are amplifiers that have one
megahertz bandwidth
and they brag about how they have one
megahertz or two mega gears bandwidth
but that's not bandwidth we can use and
by the way wide bandwidth devices or it
can be subject to oscillation
and the device could be oscillating at
100 kilohertz and you may not even know
it
and uses a power may destroy itself
in rare cases it may cook your twitter
so as much as we like to feel good about
you know using square wave to test
something
i don't use it it's not a common test uh
we use it in the old days i should say
you know in 70s and 80s
because all you need is to generate a
generous square wave and then you could
look at this on an
oscilloscope and immediately see some
effects like the uh
you know band limiting or if there was
oscillations and so forth you could see
around the edges
and that was a convenient way to turn an
oscilloscope into an audio
analyzer today i have a perfect audio
analyzer
why try to interpret the square wave
when i can
literally look at the frequency response
and i can look at distortion i can look
at noise
there's just really no reason to resort
to a square wave
um i shouldn't say no reason if you have
a
specific thing you're investigating like
you're designing an amplifier and what
have your square wave may tell you
something
but for the purpose of analyzing an
audio device
it's just you know what is the point of
having all these tones running like this
doesn't look like music no music looks
like
this nothing again can generate this
at all i mean we just don't have
anything that has infinite bandwidth as
soon as you use a microphone to record a
square wave you get the same thing you
get a
whole bunch of it truncated because the
frequency response of a microphone is
going to be like this
and it's going to chop off a lot of
these things so
really don't keep asking
me for square wave that's it is not a
proper test if i use
it uh there'll be tons of manufacturers
complaining saying hey why are you
throwing these high bandwidth signals at
audio devices it's not a valid test and
they would have a good point in there
occasionally i will use a square wave
let's say you want to look at how a
digital filter is in a dac
and i'll show you where there's ringing
before and after
but also know that that ringing often
happens the frequency of those ringing
is well above audio bands so a lot of
people get concerned that oh there's
ringing there's previewing impulse ring
and it's like no if the ringing is not
audible
then it's not audible so and by the way
when you band limit a
system like as you know digital format
is you're gonna get drinking there's
just no
you know if somebody spotted so if i go
back to my uh
you know let's go one kilohertz you're
gonna get ringing
and that's the math says you will but
this frequency of these things is very
high
look at how closely they are spaced so
you know you're not it's not going to be
that that audible to you
okay um this comes with square wave and
what it is is super important signal
processing it will come up often you may
it'll actually show up in jitter
measurements and uh and i'll show you
some of that in the future so
please internalize this simple concept
that the square wave has infinite energy
has infinite odd harmonics so whatever
frequency you say one kilohertz
is gonna have another pulse of three
kilohertz another pulse of five
kilohertz and it goes off forever
and that the shape sort of is drops by a
factor of one over
whatever the harmonic order is so you
can see it dropping off
so often times um the digital
circuits when they're communicating the
microprocessor in the device and it's
doing things
it's always has digital pulses and
therefore has a lot of square waves
and if these square waves bleed into the
analog section they don't just generate
one frequency how many frequencies do
they generate
a whole bunch of harmonics and
oftentimes i can spot this in a spectrum
display
and i'll just tell you hey that looks
like a square wave
in there because i can see that it goes
in this odd harmonic cadence
and that is bleeding from a digital
portion to an analog so if you have a
usb dac or you have a streamer i can
by just looking at spectrum analysis i
can tell that a square wave
has come in there and what's the source
of a square wave usually the digital
circuits inside the dac or device that
we're looking at
av receiver and what have you so uh it's
super important to understand this
little tidbit of signal processing many
people
don't understand this and it has many
many practical consequences we don't use
it as a test signal
but we will experience it a lot as we
have these mixed signal devices that
have both digital
and analog thrown together
okay i'm going to stop the video at this
point hopefully you learned something i
know these things can be a little boring
but it's important concepts otherwise
you just won't be able to follow
some of the explanations i get for
measurements and why there are artifacts
and what have you
okay see you in a future review bye